ich werde in diesem video versuchen mich
von einer playstation 1 zu einer
playstation fünf hoch zu handeln viel
spaß playstation ist seit knapp 26
jahren nicht mehr aus der gaming welt
wegzudenken insgesamt über 450 millionen
verkaufte konsolen und selige
spielstunden und weltweiter kult dieses
jahr ist es wieder soweit eine neue
konsole kommt und die nachfrage ist so
hoch dass zum verkaufsstart quasi nicht
möglich ist eine playstation zu bekommen
viel spaß mit einer reise durch die
vergangenheit der spielekonsolen bis in
die gegenwart dieses video wird
freundlicherweise von bank unterstützen
wir starten vor 26 jahren am vierten
dezember 96 mit dieser konsole legendär
playstation 1 ist rausgekommen bevor ich
überhaupt geboren wurde
metal gear solid resident evil oder gran
turismo sind alle spiele die auf der
playstation 1 ihr debüt gefeiert haben
um zu absoluten kult spielen geworden
sind dementsprechend auch im wert
gestiegen über die letzte zeit wenn man
ein spiel in gutem zustand aber genauso
wie diese playstation wir haben jetzt
keine in besonders gutem zustand sondern
einen komplett normal gebrauchtem
zustand in so einem standard z wie es
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch zu
hause haben wenn ihr eine habt also ein
controller ein paar spiele die jetzt
nicht unendlich viel wert sind und so
die standard kabel aber keine
originalverpackung mehr
und von dieser konsole werden wir jetzt
versuchen uns hochzutreiben zu einer
playstation fünften momentan das
aktuellste überhaupt starten damit die
konsole sauber zu machen und sehen den
bestmöglichen zustand zu bringen da
musst du original sein wissen und gibt
deswegen machen wir die als allererste
mal sauber und probieren sie dann
entweder loszuwerden oder direkt gegen
der playstation 2 einzutauschen die
konsole hat jetzt keinen persönlichen
wert oder so für mich für mich ging die
reise erst bei playstation 2 los und
dann aber richtig aber trotzdem nichts
zu sehen dass hier nach wie vor alles so
mechanisch funktioniert und halt
wirklich federn in dem system drin sind
und dabei helfen dass die konsole so
funktioniert wie sie funktioniert auch
komplett zu sehen das mittlerweile halt
so ein handy in dieser größe einfach das
zehnfache oder das 20 oder 50 fache an
leistung hat es macht die konsole sauber
und probiert irgend jemanden zu finden
der mir vielleicht sagen kann wie man
mit spielen und konsolen geld verdienen
ich habe einfach nicht mal zwei minuten
meine anzeige jetzt online gestellt mit
der komplett sauber gemacht und
playstation und schaut euch mein
postfach
das sieht so aus im minutentakt kommen
hier nachrichten reihe von leuten meine
playstation kaufen wollte ich habe das
gesamte set 40 euro eingestellt und
scheinbar ist das sehr günstig für diese
super sauber gemachte playstation
deswegen werde ich den preis entgegen
genommen ein bisschen an erhöhen ich
habe das für 40 euro drinnen und leute
blieben wir also ich habe mich komplett
verschätzt mann preis und wer den preis
jetzt anziehen und hoffen dass wir so
noch ein bisschen mehr respekt es war
schön
du musst glaube ich mal die einzeltitel
checken kann es sein dass vielleicht
eins der spiele viel wert ist und das
hört sich alle melden
euro das kann nicht sein ich weiß nicht
welches ich bin halt überhaupt nicht da
wo ich hätte ein game derweil dafür 100
euro werden aber wenn die leute so
abgehen
guten abend playstation noch da
verkaufen sie auch spiele einzeln läuft
wir haben gerade danach gesucht warum
die leute so heißt sind und tatsächlich
ist in dem z was ich habe was mir nicht
bewusst war ein spiel dabei das für 70
euro alleine auf ebay verkauft wird das
war mir tatsächlich nicht gewusst ihr
müsst mir das glauben nicht so dass ich
mich jetzt am anfang des projektes
direkt buchen wollte ich hab das einfach
nicht gewusst ich natürlich bezeugen ich
habs gerade nach rund 70 euro also
wirklich kraft meine anzeige ist
deaktiviert was haben sich zu viele
leute gemeldet oder das als fake
gemeldet weil das spiel dabei ist also
dh es gibt auch jedenfalls sehr viele
leute die sehr viel plan haben
anscheinend ich gehöre nicht dazu
ich schwöre du bist so ein glück hält
jetzt bei dem anderen video blogger
immer noch dass ich musste max kurz
unterbrechen darf nicht sagen also in
allen der nächste videos passiert ich
plane ein ähnliches projekt gerade und
da ist in der ersten folge auch sowas
geistig gestört ist passiert und jetzt
schon wieder wirklich verrückt
ich habe mich dann sofort darum
gekümmert das spiel im bestmöglichen
zustand zu bringen und habe sofort
wieder bei ebay eingestellt und das hat
auch nicht lange gedauert bis direkt ein
käufer kam
es hat jetzt gerade eben tatsächlich
noch 130 geboten ich glaube aber halt
nur wegen sei komplett bin ich jetzt nur
einzelne spiele verkaufen dann habe ich
die nachher noch herumliegen das bringt
mir nichts ich kann kann nicht dann
nicht vom preis
kein stress ist alles drin ja herr war
machs gut mit den 130 euro habe ich dann
sofort wieder angefangen online zu
schauen was für konsole nicht bekommen
kann und habe angefangen auf
verschiedene optionen zu bieten und das
funktioniert rein gar nichts ich finde
keine konsolen die mir in irgendeiner
weise geld bringen könnten ich finde
keine spiele die man enger weise geld
bringen könnten dieser markt ist so hart
umkämpft dass ich einfach keine
möglichkeit sehe wie ich jetzt aus
diesen 120 euro 400 euro machen sind der
einzige kleine hoffnungsträger den ich
habe wäre dass sich defekte konsolen
kaufe die repariere und wieder verkauft
genau danach suchen jetzt und hoffe dass
wir so vielleicht schaffen dass eine
solche idee und ein paar anzeigen
geschrieben habe kann ich zumindest
sehen das immer noch bedarf an ps4 ist
und die wirklich gekauft werden das ist
schon mal sehr gut weil jetzt kümmere
ich mich darum mich einfach auf ps4
reparaturen zu spezialisieren nach drei
tagen hin und her viel bieten viel
schreiben habe ich tatsächlich eine ps4
pro gefunden die in meinem budget liegt
für 100 euro und vermeintlich defekt ist
ich glaube aber dass es nur ein software
fehler ist hier ist das gute stück aber
eine sache habt ihr euch mit sicherheit
alle gefragt wie schickst du so einfach
bei verkäufen und bei käufen dein geld
von a nach b und hier kommt bank ins
spiel bank ist eine online bank bei der
er super easy go on as safe ein konto
eröffnen könnt ohne irgendeine filiale
rennen zu müssen oder unnötigen
papierkram zu haben ihr könnt super easy
unter konten anlegen genau so wie ich
jetzt wenn ihr auf irgendwas spart zum
beispiel eine ps 5 oder so dann habt ihr
genauen überblick wie viel geld ihr habt
wie viel geld er noch sparen müsst und
außerdem listet die app euch ganz genau
auf wie viel geld die im monat
irgendwelche abos oder sonstwas ausgibt
also habt den perfekten überblick direkt
von bank organisiert und ganz ohne es zu
merken plan c pro 100 euro umsatz über
dem bank account noch einen baum tut
also etwas gutes ich könnte hier mit
bank nicht sein ich benutzt die app
selber seit anderthalb jahren als
geschäftskonto ich danke vielmals dass
sie mich diesen kanal und diese gesamte
projekt unterstützen nur durch solche
kooperationen habe ich die möglichkeit
das so zu machen wie ich das mache
klickt auf den link in der video
beschreibung durch ein konto wir kümmern
uns jetzt weiter um die reparatur der
psp pro ich glaube tatsächlich dass der
konsole eigentlich gar nichts fehlt ich
habe den fehler coaching gegoogelt und
das bedeutet dass es ein fehler mit der
festplatte gibt es gibt aber zwei
möglichkeiten entweder die festplatte
ist kaputt oder ließ einfach nur nicht
richtig eingesteckt hoffen wir mal das
es punkt zwei ist wenn nicht haben wir
noch 20 euro unsere gebrauchte
festplatte zu kaufen aber das sollte
eigentlich kein problem sein vorteil ist
wir haben pro dies noch einmal mehr wert
songs daraus mehr geld machen ich
probiere jetzt mal lässt ich habe damit
angefangen die festplatte auszubauen und
zu gucken ob die einfach nur wie ein
wackelkontakt hatte das war es aber
nicht dann habe ich die ausgebaut und an
meinen rechner gehangen um die einfach
komplett zu überfahren also ich hab dir
einfach formatiert wieder eingebaut die
software von der playstation website
selber runtergeladen einfach drauf
gezogen und es hat funktioniert ich habe
direkt max angerufen weil der die ganze
zeit im prozess dabei war es war
komplett unvorstellbar für mich dass das
wirklich der fehler war und dass die
leute das nicht selber gemacht haben
aber ihr seht ja selber wie happy ich
darüber waren dass es wirklich nur
dieser fehler
[Musik]
dann habe ich die playstation einfach
nur noch schnell sauber gemacht um die
in den bestmöglichen zustand zum
verkaufen zu bringen das ist für mich so
unbegreiflich wieso leute sowas einfach
so gehen lassen also es hat mich
wirklich fünf minuten googeln um eine
stunde arbeit gekostet ich musste nichts
mit elektronik machen ich habe eine
schraube gewechselt aber solche sachen
gehen halt einfach nicht kaputt mit ein
bisschen arbeiten ein bisschen köpfchen
und google ist es wirklich für jeden
möglich wenn ich jetzt also mehr leute
findet die playstation anbieten die in
solch guten zustand sind dann kann ich
sie genauso bis auf die 400 euro kommen
ich für die facebook brauche und genau
das mache ich auch also einfacher geht's
ja wirklich ich hab die konsole dann
eingestellt bilder daran dass rom
konsole samt fotografiert eingestellt
und eine auktion auf ebay parallel zu
meiner ebay kleinanzeigen anzeigen
gemacht anzeige anzeige anzeige und was
damit passiert ist ist für mich wirklich
unbegreiflich weil ich weiß nicht wer
jetzt noch eine ps4 kaufen will das ist
ja eine ps4 pro also das beste modell
von der ps4 dass es gibt aber trotz
alledem waren sollte man jetzt ein paar
ski pro kaufen anscheinend gibt es aber
40 leute die anderer meinung sind denn
unsere pässe pro steht mit 40 geboten
auf 231 euro bei ebay damit die leute
sehen das ist kein fake ist das hier ist
meine anzeige
das hier sind die bilder die ich gemacht
habe habe ich natürlich ausgeschnitten
weil ich professionell auftrat bin damit
dass es einfach besser wirkt und die
leute mir mehr geld geben und das hat
tatsächlich funktioniert ihr könnt sehen
das ist er ihr das hier ist die anfrage
doch ich glaube das ist normal ich hatte
ja vorher extra gekippt die ps4 pro geht
einfach unverhältnismäßig gut jetzt
gucken wir mal hier damit die leute
wissen dass real ist das hier ist der
philips account der einzig wahre fr
doppel y psv das ist mein alter youtube
name bitte gibt ja nicht bei google ein
sonst findet ihr ganz komische sachen
das aber mein bild 231
und die auktion läuft noch eine stunde
also sind wir geisteskrank hoch wir
haben jetzt irgendwie zwei wochen oder
so dafür gebraucht also es hat schon
wirklich sehr viel zeit in anspruch
genommen aber tatsächlich hat es sich
ausgezahlt
[Musik]
aber neunzehnten kommt noch mal so eine
neue welle und da müssen wir dann
rheinhessen kennen aber es stimmt
tatsächlich also auch wenn ich das geld
bekomme jetzt unendlich schwierig apps
15 bekommen weil die einfach so begehrt
ist und die stückzahlen halt so super
niedrig sind wir sind auf dem richtigen
weg zumindest schon mal das geld für die
ps 5 zu verdienen wie das gebot ausgeht
erfahrt ihr in einem segment geschnitten
das ist meine anzeige 275 euro 45 gebote
das hier sind die verschiedenen leute
die geboten haben also es sind wirklich
so viele fake-accounts kann ich gar
nicht machen das sind alles irgendwelche
leute mit 300 bewertungen 90 bewertungen
000 bewerb 274 euro von kristin eine
person bei der ebase 2014 besteht die
bewertungen hat also es ist wirklich
verrückt ich verstehe nicht warum jemand
so viel geld dafür ausgeben sollte die
haben jetzt noch 48 sekunden auf der uhr
vielleicht gehen wir sogar noch höher
als 275 hallo gebt mir noch mal ein
bisschen mehr geld bitten man darf halt
nicht vergessen dass wir auch immer noch
30 euro übrig haben weil wir halt nicht
mal die kompletten 130 für die für die
psp pro ausgegeben haben komplett vor
wie einfach wird es an gemacht die
neueste konsole zu kommen 275 euro wer
gibt 275 euro für die ps4 pro aus es ist
aber gut für uns denn wir stehen bei 305
euro brauchen nur noch 95 euro um uns
zur ps 5 digital version hoch gearbeitet
zu haben und da müssen meine bekommen
das heißt wir müssen die nächsten tage
noch mal vertrauen denn wir haben auch
nur noch drei tage
ich hoffe ich werde nicht abgezogen das
einzige was mir gerade vorstellen kann
da jetzt hat halt auch eine person
gekauft die 0 bewertungen grundsätzlich
sind alle gebote bei ebay verbindliche
modus kann mir eigentlich nur vorstellen
dass wir abgezogen werden
wenn jetzt auf den weg die zeit ps
verbrauch zu holen das hat so gut
funktioniert dass ich das rad gar nicht
neu erfinden muss ich kaufe einfach
wieder eine für weniger geld und
verkauft die dann auf ebay eine auktion
und hoffentlich funktioniert das ähnlich
gut die psv steht für 150 euro drin aber
ich glaube da können wir noch ein
bisschen was konnten ich konnte leider
gerade mal zehn euro herunterhandeln das
ist die neue konsole dass es die diebe
bereits verkauft haben die muss jetzt
verschickt werden mit der verfall hat
genauso wie bei der anderen ich werde
sie sauber machen fotos machen bei ebay
einstellen
das erspare ich euch aber das hat er
alles schon gesehen mittlerweile sind
vier tage vergangen ich habe weniger
haare auf dem kopf und eine ps4 weniger
ich konnte tatsächlich am selben tag die
psp pro noch mit 105 euro profit
verkaufen das bedeutet wir konnten uns
innerhalb von zweieinhalb oder drei
wochen von einer ps1 zu 410 euro
hochtreiben
die große frage haben wir es geschafft
eine ps 15 am 19
eine zweite welle max und ich haben uns
bestens darauf vorbereitet und pünktlich
im büro getroffen und unendlich viele
tabs offen haben euronics medimax
gamestop amazon spanien italien
frankreich uk und deutschland war alles
offen und wir haben darauf gekämmt eine
ps 5 zu kaufen unendlich auf die seite
refresh beides in der wunschliste gehabt
damit wir die unnötige produktseite mit
den großen bildern nicht extra laden
müssen wenn die online kommen sondern
das direkt aus der wunschliste in
unseren einkaufswagen tun können mit
anderthalb stunden verspätung kamen die
ts 15 online
wir haben beide eine bekommen
aber tatsächlich habe nicht nur ich
keine bekommen sondern macht auch wir
sind beide glücklich im besitz einer
playstation und die soll anscheinend
schon morgen gibt allerdings ein problem
das was als aller erstes ausverkauft war
und was wir beide nicht bekommen konnten
war die ps 5 digital version die ich mit
dem 410 euro hätte kaufen können ich
habe eine mit laufwerk gekauft und das
bedeutet ich habe irgendwie 90 euro von
meinem eigenen geld draufgelegt alles in
allem hat das projekt also objektiv
nicht funktioniert wir haben es nicht
geschafft uns in dieser zeit von einer
ps1 zu einer kompletten ps 5
hochzufrieden wäre es möglich gewesen
die ps 5 digital version zu kaufen
hätte es funktioniert das war aber nicht
der fall also ist das projekt faktisch
gescheitert gefühlt was aber ein voller
erfolg wir haben uns geisteskrank
schnell super easy hoch getradet ich
weiß nicht wie ich euch beweisen kann
dass das nicht gefällt da es hat einfach
wirklich extrem gut funktioniert und wir
hatten natürlich auch ein bisschen glück
dass wir so wie kunden dabei hatten um
zu easy gestartet sind da auch noch mal
vielen dank an marvin aus der community
der mehr die ps1 zur verfügung gestellt
hat ein absoluter traum
außerdem haben wir jetzt eben zum
release apps 50 leider noch nicht bei
mir angekommen kommt aber morgen mit dhl
express an
ich vergesse nicht auf ins tor vorbei zu
schauen damit ihr sehen können wie ich
die auspacke vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren damit ihr kein video mehr
verpasst und direkt mitbekommt wenn am
mittwoch das nächste video online kommt
vielen vielen dank an bank die dieses
video unterstützt haben macht's gut
freunde bis mittwoch